hello everyone and Welcome to our video
on top 10 machine learning skills
machine learning has been the Talk of
the Town lately every organization has
realized the potential of machine
learning in improving their business
objectives and attending Enterprise
goals this expanding demand has led to
many people applying for machine
learning jobs and upskilling themselves
in the field of machine learning so you
can take up this growing opportunity in
the field of machine learning and
utilize it to land yourself a very
challenging fulfilling and high-paying
job so in this video we'll be breaking
down in complete detail every skill you
would need to crack the machine learning
engineer job interview the demand for
machine learning professionals is
skyrocketing across industries from
Healthcare and finance to entertainment
and transportation organizations are
actively seeking talented individuals
who can harness the power of artificial
intelligence to drive their business
forward but what skills does it take to
become a machine learning engineer how
can you embark on this thrilling Journey
we have answers to all your questions
also if you want to become an AI expert
and gain handsome salary packages look
at a wide range of AI and machine
learning courses by simply learn in
collaboration with the top universities
across the globe by enrolling in any of
these certification programs you will
gain expertise in skills like generative
AI prompt engineering J GPT explainable
AI machine learning algorithms
supervised and unsupervised learning
model training and optimization and
there's much more on the list with
hands-on experience and tools like Chad
GPT Dal python open CV and tensorflow
you will catch the eye of top recruiters
so what are you waiting for hurry up and
enroll year of experience is preferred
to enroll in these courses so find the
course link mentioned in the description
box below so without any further delay
let's get started before moving on to
machine learning skills let's take a
quick look at who is a machine learning
engineer as machine learning is
intricately connected to data science
there are overlaps in the roles of data
scientist data analyst and machine
learning engineer however data scientist
and analysts primarily concentrate on
extracting insights from data presenting
them for organized decision making with
some knowledge of machine learning
algorithms in contrast machine learning
Engineers are exclusively dedicated to
machine learning creating software
components for minimal human
intervention to derive insights from
provided data this underscores the
emphasis on computer fundamentals and
software development as their
specialized skills to become a machine
learning engineer you need a combination
of Technical and on technical skills so
here are some essential skills required
to pursue a career as a machine learning
engineer skill number one is programming
languages strong programming skills are
essential you should be proficient in at
least one programming language such as
python Ora python is widely used in
machine Learning Community due to its
Rich libraries for example numpy pandas
tensorflow pyo that supports machine
learning tasks machine learning
algorithms and techniques you should
have a solid understanding of various
machine learning algorithms such as
linear regression logistic regression
decision trees random forests neural
network and deep learning so familiarize
yourself with these algorithms
principles pros and cons and when to use
them moving on to skill number three we
have data pre-processing machine
learning models require clean and
well-prepared data you should know how
to handle missing data deal with
outliers normalize all standardized data
and perform feature engineering
understanding data pre-processing
techniques is crucial for Effective
machine learning model training moving
on to skill number four we have data
manipulation and Analysis data is the
foundation of machine learning models
you should be skilled in data
manipulation and Analysis using
libraries like numpy and pendas this
includes cleaning and transforming data
exploratory data analysis and
understanding the statistical properties
of the data the next skill we have in
our list is machine learning libraries
and Frameworks familiarity with popular
machine learning libraries and framework
is essential some commonly used ones
include numpy pandas tensorflow and pyo
these libraries provide pre-implemented
machine learning algorithms neural
network architectures and tools for
model training and evaluation the next
skill we have in our list is computer
vision computer vision and machine
learning are fundamental branches of
computer science that can independently
fuel highly Advanced systems relying on
CV and machine learning algorithms
however their combination has the
potential to unlock even greater
possibilities and achievements
moving on to the next skills we have
neural networks like the human brains
neurons neural network are pivotal for
machine learning Engineers they consist
of layers processing input to valuable
output through parallel and sequential
computations various types exist like
feed forward recurrent convolutional and
while detailed knowledge isn't mandatory
grasping core fundamentals is essential
for aspiring machine learning Engine
moving on to the next skill it's natural
language processing natural language
processing or NLP is a fun fundamental
aspect of Machining its objective is to
impart the complexities of human
language to computers enabling them to
comprehend and interpret human
communication more effectively numerous
libraries serve as the basis for natural
language processing offering functions
to help computers understand natural
language by passing text based on syntax
extracting key phrases eliminating
irrelevant words and one prominent
example is the natural language toolkit
a widely used platform for developing
NLP related applications now that we
have seen the Technical Machine learning
engineer skills let us have a look at
the non-technical skills machine
learning Engineers require the first is
industry knowledge machine learning
projects that effectively tackle genuine
challenges are likely to achieve great
success regardless of the industry you
are involved in it is crucial to
comprehensively understand its
operations and identify ways to optimize
business outcomes moving on to the last
scale for the video we have effective
communication effective communication
plays a crucial role in facilitating
these interactions companies seeking
skilled machine learning Engineers value
candidates who can effectively convey
technical discoveries to non-technical
teams like marketing or sales
demonstrating Clarity and fluency in
their explanations remember that the
field of machine learning is constantly
evolving so continuous learning and
staying updated with the latest
developments and research papers are
essential to be a practical machine
learning engineer so that's all we had
for you in this we we can call it a rap
now if you still have any questions or
doubts let us know in the comment
section below and a team of experts will
help you at the ear least thank you so
much for being here today we'll see you
next time until then stay safe and keep
learning with simply loar staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification ation programs in
cuttingedge domains including data
science cloud computing cyber security
AI machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn n up and get certified click
here